there's only three possibilities here
either the president lied to the
american people
or he legitimately cannot remember the
council of his top military advisors in
winding down the longest war in american
history or
you have not been fully accurate under
oath general mckenzie i'll ask you which
is it i'm going to be very direct i
cannot share
advice i give the president
and i will not do that i believe the
appropriate level of our forces in
afghanistan should have been 2 500. what
did the president know did he forget
what was told to him or is he not being
truthful i view that as an inappropriate
question
well you may but the american people
don't the american people want and
deserve accountability
top generals back on the hell after
blockbuster revelations that president
biden ignored their warnings on
afghanistan house lawmakers getting
their chance to grill the top browse on
why americans and allies were left
behind enemy lines and remember how the
biden administration just handed over
kabul to the taliban when we were trying
to get everyone out general mckenzie
acknowledging today that the taliban
offered to give us control of that key
city
did he offer to allow you to have
security over all of kabul now as part
of that conversation he said why don't
you just take security for all of kabul
that was not why i was there that was
not that was not my instruction and we
did not have the resources to undertake
that mission who made the uh the
decision to turn down the taliban offer
to allow the u.s military to secure
kabul and put the safety of our troops
in the hands of the taliban i did not
consider that to be a formal offer and
it was not the reason why i was there so
i did not pursue it
dan what'd you make today
there's a couple takeaways from this
first i think the wall street journal
had the best take this morning on biden
here's a real problem with biden here he
wants to take credit for the pull out
which which a lot of americans agree me
included i didn't think we should be
there forever correct but what he
doesn't want to do is he doesn't want to
take credit for the way in which he
decided he's the commander-in-chief
right that's i mean we can fact check
that he's the guy he wants to take no
credit for at all for the disastrous
method by which he did it and he wants
to throw the military under the bus so
now he's put his own military in this
awful spot where they have to sit up
there and massage this
obvious answer did you tell joe biden
president united states to leave this
way no we didn't they can't say that so
what do they say well he may have heard
it he may have heard it wrong we said
this maybe he heard a euphemism before
this is like the i mean it's so cowardly
why not just come out and say listen i
made a mistake i wanted to get out maybe
i you know i cared a lot about the lives
of the people i mean i'm giving this guy
politics this is insane political advice
i lost my run for office right so here's
the thing you just say like i made a
mistake we screwed up we're going to
rectify it we're going to get our people
out one other thing you know i heard
millie today too caller to my radio show
said this i thought this was great he
called up and he goes listen you know
this milly character he goes this guy so
he says he called china he was going to
warn him about a nuclear attack he goes
someone should ask millie i hope someone
in congress is listening did they warn
you about the whole wuhan virus thing in
advance oh they didn't so it's a one-way
street i thought that was pretty good
those are my uh two takeaways biden's
really screwed this thing up
dana the biggest takeaway it might be
the biggest ticket item either biden
lied or he doesn't remember
well and i think that if you go back we
all knew that this was probably going to
be what came out of this because for
months the
media had been reporting that president
biden was quite proud of the fact that
he had overrun the generals and they
were planning stories like that all
around and now and the military was
planting stories saying we're suggesting
a force of 2500 stay so we all knew that
that was the case so when george
stephanopoulos does the interview with
president biden he knows because he says
you mean nobody told you that and biden
says the military george's question is
your military advisors advise us and
biden says no they were split
they weren't those three weren't but who
might have been and that was the point
that hal rogers and others got to in the
hearing which is the state department
and the national security adviser who
were suggesting troop numbers
to the president who he went with those
numbers instead of going with what the
military said i hope that this is not
the end of the accountability tour
because i do think that
the president won't take questions from
the press but he really ought to and
then i think
anthony blinken and jake sherman have to
be called up as well
what do you say harold
it was embarrassing i think to watch uh
congress
require members of our military come
before them and answer questions about
advice they give the president
donald trump would not have allowed it
to happen george bush would not have
allowed it to happen and some level of
credit you have to give to joe biden for
even allowing them to come forward
knowing that they're on their oaths and
they're going to tell the truth
two i was looking forward for to this
hearing
not to politicize and relitigate the
politicization of the of what happened
there i was more interested in now that
we are where we are
what do you guys think we should be
doing for our over the horizon strategy
are you persuaded that the president is
right because we have a
civilian-controlled military their their
their role in our military is to with
the president to be is to be his advisor
and the president ultimately will be
held responsible why because his party
will have a midterm election in a year
and a half or less or a year and a
quarter and he will be up for reelection
and he will have to stand before the
voters not the generals i would urge my
old friends there stop beating up on
millie and austin and mackenzie these
men are doing their jobs they gave the
advice that they gave and president if
you want if you want to coral coral with
with biden it was his decision now for
those who want to still be in
afghanistan and have 50 000 troops you
should just say that but to come and
have these gentlemen come before
congress to have the world witness us uh
question and i think miller kind of
looks like colonel jessup from uh from
uh from
from the
tom cruise movie
to have these gentlemen have to sit
there and and take this this political
campaigning on the part of mostly
republicans some democrats i think was
an embarrassment to the country get to
the question of the over the horizon
capacity are we threatened are we better
off and what they did they did they
answered that yesterday the answer is
to handle over the horizon but i've
never heard them say then tell us what
would you be advising now in light of
where you've got ten dead
you've got ten dead civilians because of
a faulty drone that's right you're just
gonna talk about it behind closed doors
that's how they get out of it it's not
just one lie
this isn't just so i'm not telling the
truth about what the generals told me he
lied about over the horizon he lied
about they collapsed in 11 days he lied
about the taliban advance he lied when
he said we're going to bring back every
american no matter how long it takes he
asked the afghan president to lie
so it's again this is 3.5 equals zero
this is the border is secure this guy's
a stone cold liar he has a history of
plagiarism last president he'd
embellished crowd size maybe a poll
number he was a marketer biden's just a
straight up liar okay and everybody
needs to know that now we've learned a
lot about him over these last eight
months and you can't disguise the fact
you also can't disguise the fact that
the us military to say that you train
these guys to depend on you and your
technology for 20 years and then pull
out
all the technology and the personnel and
expect them to be able to hold up and
then blame them and then blame them for
collapsing so they didn't have the will
to fight no
they didn't have the tools to fight you
didn't train them the right way you
didn't give them the right stuff you
gave them all our tech because that's
what the contractors want they did the
same thing in vietnam they did the same
thing in iraq and then the generals go
back and say you know we're going to
have to look at this from top to bottom
anybody could have figured this out when
you pull out everything they're going to
collapse and the general spoke to
authors so i think they can speak to
congress i love the way we we just
absolved the trump doha agreement which
allowed for the taliban to take all this
but we can talk about it later he bombed
them four days after the agreement
because they messed with it was his
agreement yeah but he wasn't bound by it
so how's biden bound by it the taliban
had already taken those problems we've
had to send forty to fifty thousand four
days later
and nobody wants fifty thousand twenty
five hundred troops could not anyway you
don't need fifty dollars i need some air
strikes that's what you need here
catastrophic failures starting in the
spring at every turn biden had the
opportunity to slow down
turn off stop he ignored everyone he
the generals were pulling out of bagram
and they took a pause of four days and
he said move along he wanted to make the
speech on 9 11 about the end of war in
afghanistan and we've got 13 dead
service members because of it hey sean
hannity here hey click here to subscribe
to fox news youtube page and catch our
hottest interviews and most compelling
analysis you will not get it anywhere
else